how Khloe Kardashian plans to spend her
Mother's Day but will Tristan be there
plus Jennifer Lopez and Gabrielle Union
on assuming their real-life roles as
stepmoms hello friends this is the daily
denne and Mother's Day is right around
the corner and for newbomb Khloe
Kardashian it's shaping up to be a
special one after welcoming her first
child true just last month now a source
tells ET that the 33 year old mama is
planning to fly from Cleveland to LA
with true to enjoy the festivities with
her family the source tells us quote
this is a very special Mother's Day in
the kardashian-jenner family where Khloe
and Kylie it's their first one and it's
Kim's first Mother's Day with Chicago as
for trues dad tristan thompson the
source says he could be playing
basketball on Mother's Day so it's
unknown if we'll be there now if you're
wondering how things are between Chloe
and Tristan after he was accused of
cheating on Clos just days before true
was born well our source says the pair
hasn't spent a lot of time together
because of his basketball schedule but
they are in contact and the source adds
the time alone is good for Chloe
only time will tell what the future
holds because according to our source no
one really knows what Chloe's next steps
will be if they work through all this
they still have a long way to go to get
back a solid foundation the source says
well we know which side fans of the
Toronto Raptors are taking because
apparently the crowd during last night's
game against the Cleveland Cavaliers
included them trolling Tristan during a
free throw shot by chanting Chloe Chloe
Chloe we have that up for you at ET
online.com slash daily Denny so savage
right meanwhile speaking of savage how
about Kanye yesterday that blew up and
rightfully so and so far his wife Kim
has remained relatively quiet since his
bombshell interviews but the mom of
three did share these new snapchats
cuddling up with her baby girl Chicago
so either she's carefully deciding what
to say next about her husband or just
keeping the focus on her kids which is
exactly what Jenna Dewan is doing since
she and Channing Tatum split it's been
one month since the couple shocked
pretty much everyone when they announced
they were separating Jenna hit the
carpet with her world of dance fan
at a four-year consideration event last
night where ETS nischelle Turner found
out just how Jenna is coping these days
you look good how you doing good Jenna's
moving on but she isn't the only one
adjusting tourist split from Cheney and
here's today's awkward moment Ellen
accidentally called her by her former
last name please welcome Jenna Dewan
Tatum Jenna and Jenna Dewan sorry I have
to say before we go to break I I'm so
sorry I introduced you and I it was just
such a habit and I have to say the way
that you and Channing are handling
everything is beautiful and for your
daughter and I apologize that I just
have known both of you for so long and
I'm so used to saying right now thank
you and I think I mean honestly thank
you and and everybody for all the love
and the support I mean it's it's it's
truly like it's so moving
Jenna got a mama bear hug from JLo right
there but it's cool Jenna she was fine
everybody's fine you know what Jennifer
Lopez is more than fine
here she is stuntin on them in this
ferocious leopard dress at the world of
dance red carpet she flew solo without
boyfriend Alex Rodriguez but you know
this Mother's Day she's got two more
coconuts to help her celebrate one of
the things when we first heard that you
and Alex were dating I asked him what it
was that he loved about you and he said
what made you special is because he's
raising two girls and he's trying to
raise really strong women and they have
you as a model and that I thought was
amazing what does that mean to you for
me it's you know he's so lovely and he's
so supportive and encouraging of
everything that I do and I'm glad that
he sees me though
then I would be a good role model to his
girls you know I'm just trying to be a
good mom to mine and the best I can be
for all four of them
can you imagine JLo being your stepmom
I'm just saying Jenny needs to adopt
Denny from the block all right someone
else who knows a thing or two about
being a stepmom is Gabrielle Union and
joining me now is our Courtney Tessa who
talked to Gabby at the premiere of her
new movies breaking in last night
Courtney enjoyed ourselves last night we
were both there was fun but one thing I
gotta say is Gabrielle unions look at
the premiere fierce balled exactly she
hit the red carpet with her man Dewayne
Wade right by her side and they both
really turned it out totally you know I
was actually inside getting a drink
while Courtney was doing her thing on
the red carpet but Dwayne had the same
idea cuz we were both at the bar I know
I love that but they're serious couple
goals guy guys check out my interview
with Gabrielle talking about her fierce
new movie and her real life role at
stepmom to doing skids you looked great
on the carpet with your husband but
tonight is your big night and you're
playing a mom in this film but you're
also stepmom in real life so tell me how
that kind of crosses over what's it like
for you being a stepmom you know I think
for all caregivers we do heroic stuff
every day we just don't get credit for
it and especially moms you know but they
get celebrated one day out of the year
but they are moving heaven and earth for
their kids and I can't imagine you know
when your kids is lives are on the line
what a mom would do
so I try to bring all of that to this
role and and try to kick butt the way I
see moms kick butt every day oh my gosh
I love her I love it and she really did
kick butt in this movie we both watched
breaking in last night it was so much
fun I know I was hollering at that
screen we were both stirring the popcorn
for sure well you guys go ahead and
check out more of my interview with
Gabrielle on ET online.com right now
this corn are you thinking my job you
guys you know what tomorrow we are going
live at 12 p.m. Pacific and sitting
one-on-one with Asiana Alexis who
actually plays Gabrielle's daughter in
the movie so make sure you don't miss
that I'm also going to try and get some
13 reasons why season two scooper mer so
tune in until then like you share this
video and we'll see you back here right
here tomorrow a lot I probably am
persistent alright bye guys
[Music]